la nouvelle chance s'est envolé j'ai
besoin
la semaine prochaine on enregistrera les
nouveaux morceaux d'appeler les jeunes
et de passer du temps avec ma famille
les honnêtes à los angeles pour
enregistrer son album doit être une
étoile ville pas si une étoile arrête de
briller elle disparaît
photos parlent d'elles mêmes qu'est ce
que c'est c'est une invitation d'isabela
elle dirige une résidence pour les
jeunes artistes et pourquoi tu me la
donnes que maintenant parce que je crois
que c'est le bon moment
je ne sais même pas comment tu
t'appelles caillou capitaine caillou
merci beaucoup pour le voyage est
vraiment incroyable
c'est entendu cette mélodie dans un de
mes rêves mais j'ai l'impression que
j'ai perdu mon inspiration
si je pouvais amener ce piano sur la
lune je le ferai tiny tu sais ce pierre
on peut transporter où tu souhaites même
sur la lune si c'est vraiment ce que tu
veux c'est la deuxième fois que tu
m'appelles teennick elle s'est enfuie
elle se cache dans un petit village
italien tu ne va rien faire du tout
je
tu as un talent incroyable j'ai toujours
adoré danser depuis que je suis tout
petit maintenant que mon père n'est plus
là il faut que je travaille quand je
suis arrivé je n'avais plus goût à rien
je ne croyais plus en l'amour et je t'ai
rencontré et j'ai retrouvé les sports
les hommes on doit vraiment voyagé avec
tous ces animaux c'était le seul furie
qui se rendait sur l'île
je veux que l'appli que j'aime soit
heureuse
j'avais besoin de changer d'air il
fallait que je me recentre sur monet que
je découvre qui je suis vraiment